it's been more than three weeks since
Italy became the first country outside
China to introduce strict stay-at-home
restrictions with growing signs that
infection rates and deaths are starting
to plateau the government announced that
parents could take the children out for
short walks but the government has also
ordered the extension of restrictions to
stay in place until April the 13th and
probably for longer and the Health
Minister has warned against complacency
and OPM will conform daily preemies you
must not confuse the first positive
signals that we are seeing in these
hours of an all-clear signal data and
the statistical projections made by
experts show that we are under right
path and that the drastic decisions we
have adopted so far are starting to bear
fruit quarantine has brought financial
hardship and in some cases desperation
and that's given rise to numerous
gestures of kindness like these food
bank donations in Naples many residents
in the city's old quarter are hanging
pasta and other items from solidarity
baskets for the benefit of the jobless
and poor people without enough to eat
those who can give those who cannot take
says the sign you're all in the same
boat and we've installed row in the same
direction says the organizer angelo
pitoni
from his balcony and with that sentiment
in mind the European Union has weighed
in with a new initiative to support
short time working and avoid layoffs and
redundancies in the --use hardest hit
economies millions of people cannot go
to work but they still have to buy
groceries and pay the bills companies
are paying salaries to the employees
even if right now they are not making
money Europe is now coming to their
support with a new initiative it is
called sure
medical priority though is finding
enough beds and equipment to treat the
ever-growing numbers falling ill latest
triggers from France or a new record of
509 new fatalities and the authorities
are transferring patients between
regions to spread the pressure more
evenly
Paris's hospitals are now full and 38
critically ill coronavirus patients were
transferred by high-speed train to the
city of Rennes on Wednesday in Spain
where yet another record of 864 new
deaths were recorded in the previous 24
hours the temporary hospital created at
this Madrid conference center has been
restocked with fresh supplies every bed
can save a life and in this crisis every
minute matters
Paul Brennan al-jazeera